the european union has struck a
controversial investment deal with china
the eu has hailed the accord saying it
will give european companies
better access to chinese markets but
critics say those economic benefits
come at the expense of human rights
for seven years european union
representatives
have been haggling with china at the
negotiating table
the results were presented at a joint
virtual press conference
market access for both sides will be
improved
a level playing field means that chinese
state-owned enterprises
will no longer be given preferential
treatment through subsidies
and for the first time china commits to
following environmental
climate social as well as occupational
health and safety standards
but when it comes to those standards
chinese president xi jinping
made only vague promises in the
agreement china has imprisoned up to one
million uyghurs
in labor and re-education camps in
xinjiang province
she has promised to sign a convention
against forced labor
but no date has been set and sanctions
haven't been discussed
even vague promises around market access
haven't been convincing
what the the agreement is doing is
confirming to the chinese companies that
they have access
to the european market which they always
have
the problem is the other way around it's
about the access of european companies
to the chinese market which has always
been more closed
in terms of investment because of the
way that china entered into the world
trade organization
as a developing economy with special
rights
even though there have been some
breakthroughs concerning competition
both sides are not yet on equal footing
so they will most likely meet more often
around the negotiating table in the
coming years
all right let's bring in sophie
richardson the china director of human
rights watch sophie welcome
from your position i wonder what do you
see what do you read between the lines
of this trade deal
well i think there are two variables
here that should make everyone quite
skeptical
and the first is that the chinese
government is just devoid of credibility
when it comes to commitments not just
around human rights but around
issues of of trade or even security and
this is a government that regularly
signs
binding international agreements and
then ignores them
but i think the other variable is that
there is very strong evidence
the use of forced labor in xinjiang uh
you know that has been acknowledged by
the eu and member state governments
and there's almost no ability to do
the kind of due diligence that's
necessary to check
on that problem and so one looks at this
agreement
and really has to wonder why anybody
believes that beijing will pursue
any sorts of reforms on forced labor or
other issues in good faith
and so does that then speak to the
reason
why wasn't the eu firmer with china in
terms of a solid commitment to a
deadline
to improve both human and worker rights
well i think there are a lot of
variables at stake there and let's
recall that
the european parliament which is which
has taken a very strong stand on a
number of human rights issues in china
still has to ratify the deal but you
know even if you looked back at the last
10 years of reports by the eu chamber of
commerce
in china you know what you would see is
report after report as a report
complaining about all of the ways in
which the chinese government violates
the rules that have already been agreed
upon and so again it's very hard to see
how this new deal
would somehow be you know magically
different
sophie you raised the point that the
deal still needs to be ratified in the
european parliament
does that mean there is still the chance
of meaningful improvements
to be made to the deal well either
one hopes so either meaningful
improvements or
you know a much more uh honest
conversation
about what the eu really does value
we've heard a lot of discussion the last
couple of days about
the eu's values and how they're
reflected in this deal and i i just
struggle to see how the eu can both
condemn the existence of forced labor in
china
and then sign a deal with the chinese
government that doesn't
solve those problems first that should
be foundational if
you know the eu and and europeans really
care
that the clothes they're wearing weren't
made by forced labor
sophie richardson china director of
human rights watch thanks so much
thank you
you